it's the latest attempt to revitalize a
historic site a free space inside the
huntred shopping center a developer says
the location really would be perfect for
a diner a deli maybe even a coffee shop
and he wants to give the space away
christian casares joining us live in
studio with more well brian and denise
daper dapper companies i say is looking
to help small business owners they have
been several attempts to renovate the
historic property over the last decade
and this could finally be the final
piece to the puzzle we're looking for
somebody that's got the best concept jay
dapper has owned hundreds shopping
center for several years and is hoping
to help someone launch their business to
help boost the area it's somebody that
you know truly believes in downtown las
vegas
either a restaurateur could be a chef it
could be a cook the new business would
fill the last space inside the shopping
center while the developer says it will
generate more foot traffic for other
businesses it would have some
information about the qualifications
that the person has you know whether
they're a manager or chef or you know
they've been working in their family
restaurant for a long time and it's nice
to see people venture from you know what
you know downtown last year elliott
chester took a risk when he opened this
barber shop next door he says the
promotion would help a new owner
eliminate many headaches really giving
someone an opportunity to to live out
their dream you know a lot of the big
you know a lot of the big hurdles of an
entrepreneur opening up you know their
own businesses are all the expenses to
attract more applicants dapper tells us
he has other businesses looking to lend
a hand our business bank meadows bank
they've agreed that the winner will get
a bank account with 5 000 in it we've
got some local food vendors who have
agreed to
basically fill the restaurant with food
well the winner of the promotion will be
selected by their ideas and game plan
and even their food now dapper says he
hopes to have the new business up and
running by the start of next year
details to apply on our website
8newsnow.com christian casadas live
local now